man who writes the mmqb for sports
illustrated uh
albert beer back here on the rich eisen
show how are you albert
i'm good i'm good gotta have your head
on a swivel for bill these days huh
well i mean amazing it's amazing as i
said albert there's a new cryptocurrency
in the nfl and it's called bill coin um
and i i i didn't see this one coming i
knew they had a ton of cap space and
they might be
they might be active but not like the
leader in the clubhouse
by far and away what do you owe
this spending spree to albert brewer
well i think first of all it's you know
sort of a recognition
that they hadn't drafted well um a few
years ago and if you look at it like
2015 16 17 18 um
really just didn't do a good job which
is how this cap space was generated in
the first place because
if you don't have anybody in your own
roster to pay then you're going to wind
up with it with this sort of vacuum
um you know and i so i think it's it's
partially that i think it's an
acknowledgment that they've messed up
with even more recent draft picks like
nikhil harry and the two tight ends they
took last year
and do they need to move to fix those
positions quickly
um you know and then i think it's also
just a acknowledgement that
they're going to have to do things a
little bit differently without tom brady
as their quarterback and i think
over 20 years they got in such a comfort
zone where no matter what was going
wrong
they could find a way to work around it
um to like like and whether
you know offensive line issues brady
gets ball rid of the ball quicker
uh you know receivers who can't separate
he's gonna be a little bit more accurate
defense that can't play well we're gonna
we're cool getting into shootouts
because we have 12. all of that
you know i think there's like an
acknowledgement that now
um they have to build a little bit
differently and they have to be a little
bit more aggressive
and um they don't have the crutch of
brady anymore and so you know i think
there was
i in a lot of ways a reckoning in 2020
um and you know i think a lot of things
that maybe they believed to be true
wound up being a little bit more rickety
than they
did than they would have expected they'd
be and so
are they done like what
what other moves are are remaining do
you think yeah i mean i i'll give you
leonard fournette's name i know he's one
they've kicked tires on and
they're in it with the but with the
bucks and the seahawks on him
um you know and then i think the obvious
thing is that's
um that's sort of kind of hovering over
everything
is the quarterback and i don't think
they're done at quarterback now i can't
tell you whether or not that's going to
be a veteran
or a drastic i think they'll take
someone in the draft regardless at some
point question is where um you know but
i i think that they definitely if jimmy
garoppolo were to
become available they would definitely
be involved in that uh who knows what's
going to happen with deshaun watson or
russell wilson
um you know and then if this isn't taken
care of by the draft i think you
probably look at them taking someone
somewhere in the first three rounds
and and and maybe if they fall in love
with one of the guys in the first round
um i don't think it's any surprise that
cam newton's back for 2020
um yeah they felt like he
i think he that he was very hamstrung by
what was around him last year and wanted
to give him another chance
i i felt like all along what would be
the real surprise if they brought him
back without any real competition so i
think the real competition is
coming the question is going to be from
where and you know i started the show by
saying that uh free agency once again
has given us a season-long storyline uh
arc to follow which is will will this
work out for the patriots i mean how's
it going to work out with uh
with four new parts in agalore
and bourne and smith and henry
for a quarterback that um you know
despite his
hall of his mvp um you know
uh abilities on his resume
uh last year was still you know referred
to as a steep learning curve
i mean how does this all get put
together is definitely a story line of
2021 that i did not see coming coming
into free agency two days ago
it's amazing no ques yeah yeah and and
it's it's going to be interesting
because i do think
um you know they took the uh the the
circumstances of last year into account
like i said like they didn't put a lot
around him and i think
they felt like he could have been better
if he had a little bit more around him
so that's a factor obviously the
pandemic
um you know just changed the dynamic for
everybody you know cam
himself got covered and didn't play very
well after that
and that's just a fact um and they also
you know they didn't sign him until july
first so
yeah i mean forget like not being able
to go in the building you know he wasn't
on the team
in april may and june so they didn't get
a chance to know him or build an offense
around him until the summer
so i think all those things are factors
and you know what's so interesting to me
about
um you know the the the way that they've
sort of
went to rebuild the offense look how
tight end centric it is okay
i mean i could tell you on good
authority that was sold
to johnny smith and to hunter henry
um in getting both of those guys to come
there because you would think like if
you were one of those guys and
you know like you know if you're hunter
henry and john who signs here well why
would you go there
um what they sold those guys was this is
going to be an offense that's like the
one we ran in 2010
and 11 and 12. when we had rob
gronkowski
and um and uh and aaron hernandez and
like i think the the flip side of that
this is where you see a little synergy
with the team and the player
who was cam's most trusted target in
carolina for all those years
one guy he couldn't do without greg
right so um so i do think that you know
i mean look like i can't tell you cam
newton's gonna be the starter week one
again i think he's gonna have to compete
for it
but you know if you look at it and you
look at the way the offense is built now
around the tight
ends you could certainly see where it
would probably be a little bit more
comfortable
one for cam to play in than than what he
played in last year
albert brewer here on the rich eisen
show let's talk steelers albert
this fascinates me because bud dupree
hit it did he hit it and we were all
concerned about him being able to hit it
because of his blown out knee um and
you know late in the stages of last year
and um
and he's winding up on tennessee with
that contract and juju were all
expecting to see go
and pouncey retires but ben returns what
is this team going to be
looking like because i'll tell you right
now i i would place a bet
you know figuratively of course uh being
an nfl employee
uh i i i would place uh my belief
uh in the patriots to have a better
season than the steelers as we're
sitting here right now
what do you got for me on that front i
think it's a
i i think it's a fair thing to look at
like that those two teams have sort of
yeah i i think that you know you could
look at the steelers and say maybe
they're descending a little bit and
obviously after everything the patriots
have done they're they're
they're ascending a little bit um yeah
i look at like what the steelers are
doing as sort of a
you know they're moving in this period
where they're going to have to sort of
pay some of the guys
that they have i like assembled over the
last few years
and i think guys that were really
responsible for the 11-0 start last year
and so you know going forward what do
you do about minka fitzpatrick well
you're gonna have to pay him what are
you gonna do about tj watt
he should get a monster contract right i
think we can all agree on that
right um you know so you see some of the
pieces the younger pieces that they've
hit on
that allowed them to start the way they
started last year
and you know i think this is sort of a
period of transition where the core is
changing
from guys to like ben like stefan to it
like cam hayward uh that have been there
forever
now more towards guys like what guys
like minka fitzpatrick guys like devin
bush who i think
they still have very high hopes for even
though he got hurt last year
and so i think ben is in an interesting
spot in that
you know at his age i think you you'd
like your team to be all in
but because of where the steelers are
logistically
it's a little bit of a time of
transition for them where
you know i really do think that this is
you know in two or three years
it's going to be minka fitzpatrick tj
watt
you know devin bush's team no i
i hear you but this is big ben's last
year and you know i
that's the thing about it yeah so i mean
i know you're talking down the road but
we're talking 2021
a world in which the chiefs went and got
joe tooney to protect
um mahomes which i thought was an
outstanding maneuver on their part and
they are going to reconfigure their
lines so it doesn't look like super bowl
55 for all 17 weeks
next year and then you're you're looking
at obviously what the ravens and the
browns have in your own division in your
own house right
so yep this is this is it this is where
rubber meets road if
if if they had to have some sort of you
know rooney roethlisberger yalta summit
to just make this one year work you got
to figure that this is it
don't don't you have to yeah go now
right i mean and i i understand what
you're saying but they were
i mean they weren't quite as strapped as
like say the saints or the
the eagles were coming in but to to the
league year
but they weren't that far off you know
and
i'll add to that like kevin colbert's
year to year very much now i mean he's
been up front about that right like
every year he signed a one-year
extension and
the question is whether or not he's
gonna be back you know mike tomlin's now
been there
believe it or not this year will be his
15th year
he's gonna have been there now as long
as bill cower was there how about that
so you know you know i do think yeah it
just made you feel old there didn't i
um yeah so i mean look i i look at it
like i
you know i i think this is just sort of
the way the steelers have always
operated
where they don't really i mean
they don't really go and pounce on other
people's free agents and when they do
they're very selective
and they've hit on some of those guys
like joe hayden
that's that's one they really hit on
right like and he's come in and helped
shore up a real trouble spot for them
um so so you know you see some of the
things that they've done
um and really i mean this is just their
mo i mean this is the way they've always
operated this is why they've been who
they've been for the last
you know 30 years and um you know i
i understand because of what tampa has
done rich that like a lot of people look
at say well if you have an older
quarterback you got to do what camp has
done
and that's why you know aaron rodgers
now is ruffling feathers with the
packers and why russell wilson's
wrestling feathers with the seahawks
just i like the steelers just operate
differently than other teams you know
and i i don't know that kevin colbert
mike thomas even if they are
you know closer to the the end than they
are the beginning in their time with the
steelers
like i i don't know those guys are going
to move off of the way that they've
done business for a very long time just
because
camp uh did things a little bit
differently and won a super bowl that
way
albert brewer here on the rich eisen
show so um
you mentioned russell wilson look you
you got your ear to the ground
um you know as much as anybody else
uh albert and you're very attuned to
what you hear more than
others and so you know you've heard what
i've heard to over the last several
years rumors that russell and the
seahawks aren't really as
as copacetic as somebody who says go
hawks at the end of every interview
and we've heard that now this stuff is
out and nothing happened
you know you even heard like hey every
every year for the draft like keep an
eye on the seahawks choosing a
quarterback
doesn't happen yeah now though it's out
in the open now this what we've been
hearing rumblings is now flat out out in
the open but
stop me from you know uh from feeling
like nothing's gonna happen anyway you
know cause that's the way i feel like
it's just
it's gonna be out in the open but now
this is the ultimate shot across the bow
of whatever that means that he's going
to force his way out
or or demand his way out it doesn't seem
like this is going to happen still
am i wrong or or are you going to keep
the bears
you know you know i thought you know i
thought was interesting you know we all
made a big deal
um out of john and and look like
russell's can't make a big deal out of
it too
like john schneider showing up at um at
josh allen's pro day
was it three years ago now three years
ago now 2018 um
yeah so they made a big deal out of that
and where was john schneider last friday
do you know
was he was he at trey lances
yep he was front and center trey lance's
pro day now think about this like if he
was going to
you know say yeah if he was going to say
ohio state to go see
um justin fields or alabama to go see
mac jones it's easy to kind of
you know say okay like well i was there
to see this player that player
if you're going to north dakota state i
know they've got a lineman there who's
pretty good but
you're probably there to see the
quarterback and so yeah i just think
that like
and i know john likes to go see all the
quarterbacks in person
but to me like i think that that's like
there was something symbolic about
that too which is we're going to operate
like we've always operated
and yes you know we're going to try to
put a really good team around you
russell
but we're not going to con we're not
going to be held hostage by this
situation
we're gonna kind of move forward and i i
really have to believe
rich like just knowing what i know that
russell wilson signed his last contract
with the seahawks
things could change over the next two or
three years there could be different
people in charge for all we know
um but i i think right now um
the likelihood is that russell signed
his last contract with the seahawks
and then the question becomes okay well
then when do they move him and how does
he wind up on another team
and they have three years to figure that
out you know and so
i i don't think it happens this year in
part because
they don't have a first round pick they
don't have a clear answer on who would
be the quarterback after russell wilson
on the roster a clear path to that
because they don't have a first round
pick this year um
you know but i certainly think that this
is something that's going to linger
and again like you know i you know i
don't think that the seahawks are going
to suddenly
go on hands and knees to russell wilson
and say whatever you want
um you know and i think that that john
schneider showing up in fargo last
friday was a was as good an illustration
of that as anything that we've got
and then what's uh what's the latest on
on uh
on deshaun watson if there is one uh our
our colleague in the nfl media group um
your former one my current one jim
trotter was on the show i got steve
weich of the huddle and flow podcast on
thursday
their conversation with david culley was
something else last week and then
you know jim dropped here because i i
said on the show like look you know
if watson is going to get boxed in which
appears to be
one way that he would term it i i would
say um
and then at some point during the summer
potentially if it does go that long
they're going to force him to choose
between his money
and his principles and that's a spot
where
no athlete really wants to be certainly
if you're going to be portrayed in the
media
or certain places is something you're
not uh
and and so on and so forth that i i
asked jim like
when's he going to say something
publicly uh to change that
narrative because he could get out of
that box with just one sit-down
interview with somebody or one instagram
post and he's just like why would he
want to
say anything he's not going to win
anything by saying anything and
intimated that there's a camera crew
following him right now to chronicle
this whole thing and he will have you'll
hear from him by the time it's over is
what jim trotter had to say
what are you hearing about this whole
business right now albert
so i i gotta tell you what other teams
are getting when they're calling nick
cassario the new general manager
there nick's basically said to every
team that's called you can ask me about
any player but the quarterback
so like that's sort of what they're
being greeted with
now that doesn't mean offers aren't
being made
that doesn't mean that nick even though
he's saying he's not taking offers
isn't writing things down you know like
okay he said he'd give me this he said
he'd give me that
i like you know but right now
his stance to other teams has been i i'm
willing to talk about anybody i'm not
willing to talk about
trading desean watson um and so
you know that leaves you with a
stalemate where the team isn't willing
to talk about trading the player
and the player um doesn't want to play
for the team
so like i think like at this point like
anybody's saying they know what's going
to happen i think
there's some guesswork there but i heard
what you heard too and and on jim and
um and steve's podcast there that that
uh that deshawn did say
or that david colley did say he's our
quarterback right now
and i think that's significant too you
know because even if that's a little bit
of a slip
that means he's at least thought about
or maybe talked about internally
with nick and other people in the
building like what happens if we can't
solve this yeah but how could they not
have those conversations albert i mean i
think they'd have to yeah you'd
absolutely have to and here's the thing
here here's the thing there's no
deadline right now
like some quarterbacks like the jets
like i'll give you an example like the
jets
like if they don't deal sam darnold this
week like
then you know maybe that hurts their
value a little bit because seats
you know seats will fill up in other
places i i i honestly believe this like
deshawn watson
and russell wilson their value
like supersedes that their value those
two guys
like their teams can hold on to them and
they won't lose value they're good
enough where other teams will throw
their quarterbacks overboard to go and
get them
and so like i i just don't think that
there's any rush to do anything right
now
to me the real pressure point is the
draft because
if the texans get to like if you trade
him after the draft
now you're trading him for future draft
picks for future assets
where you don't know if that pick you're
trading for is going to be the 10th pick
of the 25th pick
if they were to trade them to the jets
or dolphins right now you know what
they know all right that's the second
pick that's the third pick
we can find his replacement with that
pick so that's why i think like the
the draft is sort of maybe the the
the next important mile post here i
think this week is fairly irrelevant to
both
um to to the value of either guy now it
seems like the bears you know teams
might
want you to give them an answer but
i don't think it hurts the seahawks or
texans to sit on
the quarterbacks right now i think where
the tech where the texans have to be
looking at going forward the seahawks
too
would be we probably should make a for
the good of our team for the good of our
franchise for the good of our 2021
season
we probably should be seeking some sort
of answer
by the time we get to the draft i mean
and then and then at some point you know
the pieces will
will maybe stay the same and you know
if that happens then then guys like alex
smith and
potentially andy dalton unless the bears
jump on him now um
right trubisky yeah all th this is going
to be
a galat right wouldn't you say there
could there could literally wind up a
glut
of quarterbacks youthful and also
highly experienced that are sitting
there saying what next
when it's outside i i agree with that
but i mean like i think i think the
other thing is too like
you know some of these teams have
placeholders where
i look like you know teddy bridgewater
is making 21 million a year
okay the panthers would happily
either figure out what to do with that
if they could wind up with deshawn
watson
you know the bears have nick foles on
their roster
do they think nick foles is going to be
their week one starter no
but at least having him there gives you
some flexibility going forward
washington
you know washington now is ryan
fitzpatrick there they think that
they're the best team in the division
they have a right to think that because
they won the division last year
and they think they can win the division
again with ryan fitzpatrick
but if deshaun watson or russell wilson
were to become available would they kick
tires on it sure
so i i do i do understand what you're
saying where
it's like well we can't bring this guy
or that guy in um
you know when deshawn watson and russell
wilson are out there still
i still look at it like you know if i'm
the bears like for example because
they've been connected to russell it's
used them
and you're looking at you're talking
andy dalton you say to andy
look we really like you we'd love to
have you in here um you haven't
you have a relationship with our office
coordinator platform in cincinnati
um we like a lot of things about you but
you just have to understand
if one of these two other guys become
available hit the brakes
huh hit the bricks the bricks may be
like that's it right like that's it but
but at least you're being honest with
the guy then right
like so i i personally think there are
ways around that don't you
i mean like it seems like a pretty
simple thing no i hear you albert thanks
for the time
you're uh you're phenomenal as always
we'll chat soon you'll be well
awesome thanks appreciate it you guys
albert brewer here on the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here